[Musica]
questo è la mappa a cui siamo più
abituati quando guardiamo il nostro
pianeta è una mappa incredibilmente
dettagliata quando guardiamo le terre
emerse
abbiamo foreste montagne e deserti e
quando però volgiamo lo sguardo verso il
mare
quello che vediamo è una distesa blu
completamente piatta ma se fossimo in
grado di mettere la testa just giusto un
pochino sott'acqua e di rimuovere questo
vedo quello che vedremo sarebbe questo
un auguro grafia incredibilmente
complessa con monti valli fiumi
sotterranei anche vulcani e questo mondo
sommerso è popolato da creature
incredibili che ci possono insegnare
come era la vieta agli albori sulla
terra oppure si potrebbero dire com'è la
vita in altri pianeti o ancora si
potrebbero fornire delle risposte per
trovare nuovi medicinali nuove cure per
le nostre malattie
eppure tutto questo guasta opportunità
di scoperte per ora è sfruttata solo in
piccolissima parte per un ventesimo come
avere un castello con venti stanze piene
di tesori e avere né aperta solo una
lasciando le altre chiuse in attesa di
essere aperte quello che noi non
facciamo ovviamente non lo stiamo
facendo per mancanza di volontà per
mancanza di desiderio verso nuove
scoperte o nuovi tesori lo facciamo
perché è incredibilmente difficile
raggiungere queste profondità quando si
parla di immersioni subacquee già
un'immersione a 50 metri è un'immersione
e tecnica che richiede delle grandi
capacità e si incorrono tra dei grandi
rischi e possono durare pochissimi
minuti per cui quando dobbiamo
raggiungere delle profondità maggiori di
fatto noi ci affidiamo totalmente a
sommergibili batiscafi o robot simile a
questi che potete vedere qui robot della
forma di siluri per esempio perfetti per
notare rapidissimi in tutte le bluff le
lunghe distanze nel mare e avere una
immagine più o meno grossolane il
fondale
oppure ci possiamo affitto
ha dei grossi robot a forma più o meno
di scatola composti da strutture rigide
schiume attuatori vorrebbe dire motori
con eliche grandi eliche che permettono
al robot di muovere e volendo
avvicinarsi al fondale interagire con
bracci robotici però possiamo capire
questi immensi veicoli soggetti ai
disturbi delle onde a correnti
sottomarine in un ambiente in cui
sensori sono molto meno efficaci di
quelli che abbiamo fuori dall'acqua
diventa incredibilmente complesso
interagire in maniera corretta evitando
magari di distruggere il robot se la
nostra corrente onda ce lo porta addosso
una parete rocciosa oppure di non
danneggiare un monet fatto raro un
corallo una specie biologica che voglio
che vorremmo prendere la risposta a
questa problematica di fatto è rivolta
sempre all'aumentare la potenza degli
attuatori quindi a rendere dei motori
più forti a utilizzare dei controllori
più precisi o dei sensori migliori ma
anche nella migliore delle ipotesi avere
delle eliche crea disturbi sull'ambiente
un po qua come quando abbiamo un
elicottero che si avvicina al suolo e si
muove tutta l'erba una sabbia che di
fatto limita la nostra capacità di
interazione allora noi ci siamo
domandati è possibile cambiare approccio
invece di nuotare nel mare e poi una
volta che raggiungiamo il fondale all
oggetto di interesse controllare
accuratamente i robot possiamo ispirarci
alla natura alle creature che già
popolano il mare per trovare un altro
modo di interazione per esempio potremmo
ispirarci a degli animali con gambe che
si muovono agilmente sia fuori che
dentro l'acqua che si ancorano
perfettamente al suolo e resistono alle
onde senza problemi e sono in grado
anche di manipolare se necessario ci
possiamo ispirare a dei granchi per
creare una nuova tipologia dei veicoli
che invece di muoversi per tutta la
colonna d'acqua e poi arrivare in
fondale vanno direttamente nel punto di
interesse e agiscono in maniera più
accurata ed efficiente
per fare questo tuttavia dobbiamo capire
molto bene come funzionano i sistemi
biologici
e dobbiamo cambiare il nostro approccio
alla progettazione quello che facciamo
tipicamente in un team di ingegneri è
l'ingegnere meccanico si occupa dei
materiali della struttura dei meccanismi
poi interviene l'ingegnere elettronico
che fa le connessioni elettriche il
controlli sta che prepara gli algoritmi
di controllo
tuttavia questo processo seriale non è
quello che segue la natura la natura
evolve insieme controllo e hardware che
vorrebbe dire evolvere insieme il
cervello il sistema nervoso e i
meccanismi quindi le gambe i muscoli e
in questa unione di interazioni noi
possiamo avere una progettazione
olistica che aiuta il compito finale del
robot nel nostro caso muoversi agilmente
in fondale senza poterlo conoscere in
maniera accurata come avviene fuori
dall'acqua e quel per questo noi poniamo
nuove domande ai nostri ingegneri
meccanici domande tipicamente che non
sono poste come come potresti con il tuo
meccanismo aiutare il controlli sta a
realizzare il suo compito di controllo o
viceversa noi possiamo chiedere
all'ingegner dell'automazione non
controllare il meccanismo che hai
davanti come se non lo conoscessi ma
devi considerare la dinamica naturale
del tuo sistema cosa farebbe il sistema
naturalmente è in vita questa dinamica
c'è sfrutta questa dinamica in maniera
più efficace con questo punto di vista
in mente e con un accurato studio
dell'animale noi abbiamo scoperto che di
fatto il gran che utilizza una strategia
simile cioè utilizza un controllo
leggermente più semplificato di
conoscere esattamente nel ping ogni
istante a che altezza il terreno e dove
deve mettere il piede insomma per dire
anche un parallelo con noi anche noi
quando corriamo non sappiamo esattamente
se il terreno e 2 cm o 3 centimetri più
in basso ma in verità demandiamo alle
componenti elastiche della gamba muscoli
tessuti molli parte del controllo per
fare in modo che piccoli disturbi
vengano rigettati o ammortizzati dalle
componenti meccaniche del in questo caso
dell'animale del granchio ode dell'uomo
con il caso della corsa
ecco con questi principi noi siamo stati
in gradi di crea di creare un nuovo
robot con delle gambe che qui vedete
saltellare sul fondale e questo robot
non a conoscenza di nulla di quello che
c'è intorno a lui sa solo che in
contatto deve spingere e le molle che
ora sono nascoste nel in questa parte
bianca nel ginocchio fanno il compito di
evitare piccole asperità del terreno ma
anche magari di adattare le gambe quando
grandi asperità vengono trovate e questo
è solo uno di un vantaggio abilitante
che ci permette di muoverci in fondale
senza conoscerlo ma ci sono anche altri
vantaggi in questo ribaltamento di
approccio per esempio possiamo essere
incredibilmente meno invasivi dal punto
di vista acustico
ora se potete chiudere gli occhi per
pochissimi secondi
troverete il suono di un robot marino
tradizionale pronti
eccolo qua
[Musica]
penso ma non è proprio rassicurante per
un pesce che vogliamo no che vogliamo
magari vedere in maniera delicata senza
invadere il suo ambiente perché il
comportamento se 9 inalterata allora
sentiamo ora qual è il suono del nostro
robot ispirato al granchio di nuovo ops
riproviamo ecco è questo suono più
simile quasi a una molla proprio o un
arco che viene rilasciato quasi
indistinguibile dal rumore di fondo è
incredibilmente discreto non è continuo
come quando vengono fatte le manovre per
un elica tradizionale e questo è solo
nel movimento ma ora immaginate invece
un altro esempio quando voi dovete
magari scattare una foto di notte e
quindi avete una camera che tenete a
mano o sul cavalletto
ecco fare un campionamento accurato
sott'acqua con un robot tradizionale
equivale a questo ad avere quel suono
sempre attivo e i disturbi che per
quanto voi potete provare a compensare
vi faranno sempre muovere un pochino
invece quello che noi riusciamo a
realizzare grazie alle nostre gambe sono
video di questa di questo tipo di questa
tipologia qui in cui di fatto abbiamo lo
sfondo perfettamente a fuoco mentre dei
componenti che si muovono tracciano
delle scie come nelle immagini a lunga
esposizione che voi potete avere quando
fate queste queste fotografie sfruttando
il cavalletto questo e per dimostrare
come un robot che cambia l'approccio può
rendere dell'esplorazione delle
misurazioni incredibilmente più accurate
e precise rispetto a un robot che invece
deve farlo in condizioni di disturbi
continui che deve compensare noi eravamo
inizia abbiamo iniziato diciamo questa
strada questa avventura
guardando a quel qui 19 ventesimi che
erano inesplorati
ma poi quando abbiamo iniziato a vedere
anche quell un ventesimo che l'ha già
esplorato
sarà il nostro robot quello che abbiamo
scoperto che la quantità di rifiuti
marini che arrivano in superficie di
fatto affondano in gran parte
raggiungono il fondale magari in zone di
accumulo che sono determinati dalle
correnti o da condizioni geologiche che
fanno degli imbuti e degli accumuli di
spazzatura
per questo abbiamo detto perché non
sfruttare questi vantaggi e queste
conoscenze questi approcci che stiamo
sviluppando per aiutare l'ambiente per
aiutare la pulizia dei fondali e di
nuovo ci siamo rivolti verso delle altre
strategie più espirate in questo caso al
polpo per scoprire come l'animale
utilizzasse sfruttasse le componenti
morbide del suo braccio unite con
attuazioni semplici di nuovo come prima
attuazione che semplifichino la
complessità dei movimenti ma che renda
in maniera altrettanto efficace e
delicata e la manipolazione di oggetti
la presa in questo caso noi non sappiamo
esattamente l'oggetto come ma attuiamo
il braccio nella stessa maniera e
lasciamo alla componenti meccaniche
morbide il compito di adattarsi
all'oggetto e questo ci ha permesso di
fatto di creare una nuova tipologia di
veicoli e di integrare sul nostro robot
questo manipolatore morbido che è
costituito anch'esso da componenti
cedevoli che possono essere utilizzate
per raccogliere i rifiuti in fondale
guidato dalle telecamere e con il utente
esterno nel loop in questo caso
ovviamente noi possiamo utilizzare
ancora altre tipologie di locomozione
perché una gamba differenza di un'elica
può essere utilizzata in mille modi
e così noi possiamo realizzare delle
camminate più accurate più semplici più
lenti o più veloci dipendentemente dal
lo scopo che dobbiamo avere per esempio
possiamo vedere l'oggetto da lontano e
muoverci velocemente e quando vogliamo
prenderlo ecco che possiamo muoverci in
maniera più accurata delicata per
arrivare immediatamente sopra ad essa è
a questo punto allungare il nostro
braccio morbido del nostro
vita che vedete nella parte terminale
del manipolatore e afferrare l'oggetto è
come in questo caso qui noi possiamo
prenderlo a formare afferrarlo e riporlo
in una sorta di raccolta in questo test
che abbiamo fatto ormai circa un anno fa
in collaborazione con un'altra
università internazionali che era
interessata a utilizzare il nostro robot
come strumento per testare questo loro
braccio ecco da quella da questi
primissimi esperimenti noi siamo andati
ancora avanti e abbiamo realizzato di
fatto un'architettura più complessa un
manipolatore migliore e una stazione di
raccolta sottomarina che di fatto è come
se fosse un piccolo cestino dei rifiuti
con il nostro robot che in questo caso
stava campionando stava ripulendo un
area 15 metri di profondità prendeva gli
oggetti e le riportava in questa
stazione di raccolta per pulire varie
aree magari realizzare in futuro una
serie di questi robot che possano pulire
varie aree limitate ovviamente perché
non possiamo muoverci moltissimo ma
queste zone di accumulo potrebbero
essere veramente ripuliti da questa
tecnologia
ecco quindi in conclusione diciamo che
noi abbiamo afferrato per prima cosa i
principi biologici e biologici che ci
hanno permesso di costruire questa nuova
categoria di robot un po folli rispetto
ai robot tradizionali totalmente diversi
che utilizzano totalmente altri
algoritmi e stata una grande scommessa
che è stata vinta grazie alla
comprensione della natura e adesso
speriamo con il nostro strumento di
ridare alla natura qualcosa in più dal
punto di vista del monitoraggio della
cura e della pulizia
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]